Jak pan słyszy kolegów z koalicji 15. października
kolegów z 3. drogi
kolegów z psl-u
przecież w sprawie majątku
dziedziczenia
dokumentacji medycznej można iść do prawnika
można podpisać umowę
ale ja nie jestem człowiekiem 2. kategorii
żeby robić takie rzeczy
ja jestem obywatelem rzeczpospolitej polskiej
noszę polski dowód i chciałbym
żeby państwo traktowało mnie z godnością
bo ja nie jestem spółką handlową
tworzę związek partnerski prawie OD ćwierć wieku
który chciałbym
żeby w świetle państwa był widoczny
ja jestem byłym prezydentem słupska
który słynął między innymi z tego
że z całej polski i ze świata przyjeżdżali ludzie
żeby udzielić im ślubu
ja chciałbym w końcu i nareszcie także poczuć
Jak to jest Po 2. stronie
Po prostu Po ludzku cieszyć się tym szczęściem i
dlatego są tak ważne te związki partnerskie